When one is in a bad place in one’s head,
the modern world offers three main sources
of solace: psychiatric medication, CBT and
psychotherapy. Each has its own advantages
and drawbacks. Medication can be exemplary
in a crisis, at points when the mind is so
under siege from fear, anxiety or despair
that thinking things through cannot be an
option. Correctly administered, without requiring
any conscious cooperation from us, pills play
around with our brain chemistry in a way that
helps us get through to the next day – and
the one after. We may get very sleepy, a bit
nauseous or rather foggy in the process, but
at least we’re still around – and functioning,
more or less.Then there is Cognitive Behavioural
Therapy (CBT), normally administered by psychologists
and psychiatrists in six to ten hour-long
sessions which teach us techniques for arguing
rationally with, and with any luck at points
controlling, the ghoulish certainties thrown
up by our internal persecutors: paranoia,
low self-esteem, shame and panic. Lastly there
is psychotherapy, which from a distance looks
like it has only drawbacks. It has a very
hard time showing its efficacy in scientific
trials – and has to plead that its results
are too singular neatly to fit the models
offered by statisticians. It takes up a large
amount of time, demanding perhaps two sessions
a week for a couple of years – and is therefore
by far the most expensive option on the menu.
Finally, it requires active engagement from
its patients and sustained emotional effort;
one cannot simply allow chemistry to do the
work. And yet, psychotherapy is, in certain
cases, a hugely effective choice, which properly
alleviates pain not by chance or magic, but
for three solidly-founded reasons: – Our
unconscious feelings become conscious A founding
idea of psychotherapy is that we get mentally
unwell, have a breakdown or develop phobias
because we are not sufficiently aware of the
difficulties we have been through. Somewhere
in the past, we have endured certain situations
that were so troubling or sad, they outstripped
our rational faculties and had to be pushed
out of day-to-day awareness. For example,
we can’t remember the real dynamics of our
relationship with a parent; we can’t see
what we do every time someone tries to get
close to us, nor trace the origins of our
self-sabotage or panic around sex. Victims
of our unconscious, we can’t grasp what
we long for or are terrified by. In such cases,
we can’t be healed simply through rational
discussion, as proponents of CBT implicitly
propose, because we can’t fathom what is
powering our distress in the first place.
Therapy is a tool for correcting our self-ignorance
in the most profound ways. It provides us
with a space in which we can, in safety, say
whatever comes into our heads. The therapist
won’t be disgusted or surprised or bored.
They have seen everything already. In their
company, we can feel acceptable and our secrets
sympathetically unpacked. As a result, crucial
ideas and feelings bubble up from the unconscious
and are healed through exposure, interpretation
and contextualisation. We cry about incidents
we didn’t even know, before the session
started, we’d been through or felt so strongly
about. The ghosts of the past are seen in
daylight and are laid to rest. There is a
second reason psychotherapy can work so well:
– Transference: Transference is a technical
term that describes the way, once therapy
develops, a patient will start to behave towards
the therapist in ways that echo aspects of
their most important and most traumatic past
relationships. A patient with a punitive parent
might – for example – develop a strong
feeling that the therapist must find them
revolting, or boring. Or a patient who needed
to keep a depressed parent cheerful when they
were small might feel compelled to put up
a jokey facade whenever dangerously sad topics
come into view. We transfer like this outside
therapy all the time, but there, what we’re
doing doesn’t get noticed or properly dealt
with. However, therapy is a controlled experiment
that can teach us to observe what we’re
up to, understand where our impulses come
from – and then adjust our behaviour in
less unfortunate directions. The therapist
might gently ask the patient why they’re
so convinced they must be disgusting. Or they
might lead them to see how their use of jokey
sarcasm is covering up sadness and terror.
The patient starts to spot the distortions
in their expectations set up by their history
– and develops less self-defeating ways
of interacting with people in their lives
going forward. – The First Good Relationship
We are, many of us, critically damaged by
the legacy of past bad relationships. When
we were defenceless and small, we did not
have the luxury of experiencing people who
were reliable, who listened to us, who set
the right boundaries and helped us to feel
legitimate and worthy. Image result for Winnicott
child However, when things go well, the therapist
is experienced as the first truly supportive
and reliable person we’ve yet encountered.
They become the good parent we so needed and
never had. In their company, we can regress
to stages of development that went wrong and
relive them with a better ending. Now we can
express need, we can be properly angry and
entirely devastated and they will take it
– thereby making good of years of pain.
One good relationship becomes the model for
relationships outside the therapy room. The
therapist’s moderate, intelligent voice
becomes part of our own inner dialogue. We
are cured through continuous, repeated exposure
to sanity and kindness.  Psychotherapy
won’t work for everyone; one has to be in
the right place in one’s mind, one has to
stumble on a good therapist and be in a position
to give the process due time and care. But
that said, with a fair wind, psychotherapy
also has the chance to be the best thing we
ever get around to doing.
If you are interested in trying psycotherapy,  The School of Life offers a service in person in London,
or by Skype around the world.  Click on the link for further details.